Did you know the global average cost of a breach is $4.42M USD?
And it takes on average 287 days to identify and contain a breach?
The problem is many of the tools in the marketplace
today
fail to adequately stop and prevent breaches.
Hi, my name is Tim Brantner and I'm with IBM Cloud.
Today I have the honor of talking to you about
the IBM Cloud Security and Compliance Center
and how it can help you solve this problem in one view.
As customers encounter moving regulated workloads
to the cloud,
they have to keep several things in mind and achieve.
They want to manage risk and compliance
with as much automation and standardization as possible
to increase effectiveness and lower costs.
They want to ensure data protection with concepts
like zero trust
by implementing least privilege for their identity access management,
or ensuring storage is encrypted.
They want to automate continuous detection and response for their misconfiguration of cloud resources
to reduce the probability of being the next big data breach in the news.
They want to make it simple to infuse security
and privacy for their cloud developers with DevSecOps.
But before we get into IBM Cloud Security and Compliance Center (SCC),
first, we have to talk about CSPM, or cloud security posture management.
It is a category of security products
designed to identify misconfigurations and compliance risks in the cloud.
CSPM tools work by examining a cloud environment
against a defined set of best practices
and known security risks.
It helps cloud applications be more secure
and ensure compliance with regulatory or corporate compliance standards.
We have a video entirely on the CSPM subject
done by one of our great team members, Janet Van.
What is SCC?
SCC is IBM Cloud's answer for simplified and
centralized security compliance posture.
It is geared for enterprises with regulated
workloads needing to accelerate public cloud adoption.
We want your workloads to be secure by default
with the easiest onboarding experience.
That's why we made SCC part of the IBM Cloud platform.
No installing, no instances to provision, just there by default.
And with every IBM Cloud account.
From there, it's simple to start seeing results.
IBM Cloud is the only cloud service provider that has the ability to scan other clouds.
The only one that has depth in IBM Cloud,
and continue to expand our hybrid multi-cloud capabilities with IBM Cloud Satellite.
SCC is the central way to proactively enforce
or prevent misconfiguration
for all IBM Cloud services.
All this while providing the best level of production experience:
stable, reliable, scalable and extensible
through APIs and Terraform templates.
As well as integrations with cool leading partners like Tanium, Caveonix, NeuVector,
Twistlock and our OpenShift compliance operator.
So, let's dig in.
First, how do I access SCC?
Well, it's as easy as logging into IBM Cloud on ibm.com
and go into the left-hand hamburger menu to find "Security and Compliance".
Or, in this example,
you can click on the Security and Compliance widget that gives you a quick snapshot
of your security score and ops detractors.
Or, you can click "Manage" in the top nav and select "Security and Compliance".
Once you get into the SCC experience, there's several ways to get started.
We have several examples, videos and links directly to documentation.
And besides, we're constantly making onboarding experience easier and easier.
When monitoring for configuration compliance,
you'll start off by selecting a pre-defined profile or creating a profile of your own.
A profile is a grouping of control implementations that we call "goals".
Once you have what you want to check,
you'll need to identify what resources you want to run those checks on.
We call those set of resources a "scope".
Then once that is ready, you'll set up a collector and scan details.
At that point, you have an automated scan providing continuous compliance and your compliance score.
So let's say you're monitoring, but want to be a little bit more proactive.
That is where our configuration governance capabilities come into play.
Configuration governance enables you to define, manage, enforce
and monitor the configuration rules of your IBM Cloud resources.
It's set up by defining, customizing and enabling those configuration rules,
or you can group them together in what we call "configuration
rule" templates.
Once you have set up compliance scans, enabled configuration rules, and set security alerts,
you'll have a nice dashboard -- like this one.
This one dashboard provides a quick view of all three capability areas of SSC
and allows  you to manage your security and compliance posture from one place.
Or, if UI not your thing,
we have a full list of APIs and CLIs available to interopt with your security tools.
So there you have it.
You just had a whirlwind tour of the IBM Cloud Security Compliance Center.
Honestly, there's so much more value inside
of it that I want you to go check out, but just keep this in mind:
it's IBM Cloud's answer for centralized security and compliance posture
for enterprises with regulated workloads
needing to accelerate public cloud adoption.
Thanks for watching and hope to catch you in the next video.